اه الآن في عرفة هذه القاعة
تم استخدام حفل الزفاف من قبل موظفي منظمة أطباء بلا حدود
وأسرهم للجوء هناك
تم إخطار الجيش الإسرائيلي أه
من قبل منظمة أطباء بلا حدود ليقول أنه كان المكان
مع المدنيين فقط الذين
كانوا يبحثون عن الأمان يوم الاثنين اه
ربما مرت قذيفة دبابة
مرت هذه النافذة من خلال حفل الزفاف
القاعة وخرجت بهذا من هذا المكان
هنا كانت فتاة صغيرة
الذي كان يسمى ملاك الذي كان على محمل الجد
المصاب الذي تم نقله إلى المستشفى
المستشفى الأوروبي الذي كان المستشفى
أقرب ولكن بشكل مأساوي
توفيت متأثرة بإصابتها
في اليوم التالي ارتدى الجزء السفلي من الخزان
النقوش باللغة العبرية وكما أنا
قال لم تنفجر وإلا لكان قد حدث
لقد كانت تضحية تظهر ذلك في غزة
لا يمكننا أن نكون آمنين في أي وقت
مكان
ذ